>> Guy Lamolinara:
Good morning everybody,
so glad to see you all
here and thanks for coming
to the National Book Festival.
I'm Guy Lamolinara and I work
at the Library of Congress
in a Division appropriately
called the Center for the Book.
All day here at the Library
of Congress National Book
Festival we are recognizing
and celebrating the
importance of reading
and authors and books.
The Library of Congress
makes it seem easy
to do this each and every year.
But the truth is the National
Festival, Book Festival,
is a huge undertaking.
It is a huge financial
undertaking but it is free
for everyone thanks
to our generous supporters
and sponsors.
Spread the joy of reading
with your gift online
at loc.gov/donate.
You can do that from the
festival lab or you can do it
when you purchase books today.
And now on to our main event.
David Ezra Stein is a creator
of many award winning picture
books including Interrupting
Chicken and the Elephant
of Surprise,
which was awarded a Caldecott
Honor as well as Ice Boy,
Because Amelia Smiled, Dinosaur
Kisses and I'm My Own Dog.
David received the Ezra Jack
Keats new writer award in 2008.
And his books have
received numerous awards
and have been named to many,
many book lists including
Publisher's Weekly,
Best Children's Books
of the Year
and School Library Journal
Best Books of the Year.
David is a graduate of the
Parson's School of Design
in New York where he studied
under author/illustrator
Pat Cummings.
David has worked in many,
many fields as a window
display artist, as a puppeteer
and puppet builder, an interior
and set design illustrator.
He's done cartoons for
the New Yorker Magazine.
And his books have
been translated
into so many languages I can
hardly tell you, Chinese,
Korean, Japanese, Spanish,
Catalan, French and Finnish.
David was born in Brooklyn,
New York and he lives
with his family in
Kew Gardens, New York.
Please welcome David Ezra Stein.
[applause]
>> David Ezra Stein:
Hey everybody.
Thank you, Guy.
[applause] It's nice to be back
at the National Book Festival.
I was here when my first
chicken book came out,
Interrupting Chicken.
That was some years ago
and that was a lot of fun.
So I'm looking forward to
celebrating this new book,
Interrupting Chicken and
the Elephant of Surprise.
So we're going to read
the story together.
I'm going to get kind of messy
and do some painting up here.
Maybe you've seen people
drawing but I don't know
if you've seen anybody
using acrylic paint up here.
We're going to get
colorful and messy.
So how's your summer
going, everybody?
It's the end of the summer.
You guys having a good time?
>> Yes.
>> David Ezra Stein:
Is anybody back
in school yet, back in school?
Oh man, ok.
Well that's exciting.
Anybody just started
kindergarten?
Yeah, wow.
My daughter is five and she's
about to start kindergarten
next week.
So I am probably more
nervous than she is
so I'm not really
showing that to her.
I'm trying to keep
that to myself.
But I think she's going
to have a good time.
But when I, you know, when
I was in kindergarten that's
when I learned to read.
And it was already halfway
through kindergarten
before I knew how to read
and I remember trying to read
a book over the winter break
and it was about a moose who
finds an egg and he tries
to raise it until it hatches.
And I was reading the whole book
but there was this one
word I couldn't get.
I just couldn't figure it out.
It was too complicated.
It started with a Ch and I
just couldn't figure it out.
It had all these letters in it.
The last letter was an n. Can
anybody guess what the word was
that I couldn't read?
Yeah, I could not read
this word chicken,
actually it was chickens
because the chickens come back
to get their egg from
the moose at the end,
I think that was how it went.
It's been a long time
since I read that book.
So I finally just memorized the
word chickens and when I got
to the part of the book that
said chickens I said chickens.
And then I knew how to
read and it was fantastic.
And I could go to my school
library, I was very lucky to go
to my school library and just
walk in and nobody bothered me.
I could just go take a book,
whatever book looked interesting
to me, and just read it and
nobody asked any questions,
as far as I remember, it
was just me and the book.
And so I wish that for
all of you and I hope
that you have a great time
in your school library
and reading with your parents.
So I'd like to read you
Interrupting Chicken
and the Elephant of Surprise
by David Ezra Stein, me.
[laughter] Ok so the cover
says Interrupting Chicken
and the Elephant of
Surprise, what a surprise.
Chicken, there are no
elephants in this book.
And then see in the
corner there?
Who's that little guy
going hee, hee, hee, hee?
An elephant.
Wow this works, ok.
Let's see, so Interrupting
Chicken
and the Elephant of Surprise.
Interrupting Chicken
and the Elephant
of Surprise, I said
that already.
Oh man but anyway you can see
that this is the chicken's home,
her porch and then you can
see the school bus coming
to drop her off, right?
And all the interesting
things that you can look
at when you look at the book.
It was after school for
the little red chicken.
Well chicken, said poppa,
did you have a good
day at school today?
Yes, poppa, and today my teacher
told us every story has an
elephant of surprise.
So let's read a story and
we'll find the elephant.
Chicken, she wasn't
talking about an elephant,
she was talking about
an element of surprise.
What's an element of surprise?
It's the part of the story that
makes you say woe, I didn't know
that was going to
happen, said poppa.
An elephant in a story
always makes me say woe.
So please let's read
a story together.
Alright fine but I don't expect
you'll find any elephants
in this story.
The ugly duckling, oh man this
is going to be tough to read.
[laughter] I think
my eyes are dried up.
Ok, after a long, lonely winter
in the cave the ugly duckling
was growing desperate.
I don't care if they
tear me to pieces.
I must be near those glorious
creatures for just one moment,
he said, as he flung himself
toward the flock of swans.
To his amazement the
graceful birds did not attack
or tease him but seemed to
except him as one of their own.
He peered into the water at his
reflection, gasped and said,
surprise, I'm an elephant.
Thank you for finding me.
No problem, we learned
about you in school.
Chicken, there are no
elephants in the Ugly Duckling.
Every good story has one,
that's what my teacher said.
That's ridiculous.
Is the Ugly Duckling
a good story?
Well yes but, then it must
have an elephant of surprise.
Let's try another book.
Rapunzel, enchanted
by Rapunzel's beautiful singing
the prince drew near the tower.
He had waited for this night.
Rapunzel, Rapunzel, he
called, let down your hair.
Silently a braid of Rapunzel's
hair slid down the tower wall.
Come to me my prince, called
a melodious voice above.
With all haste the
prince began to climb.
When he reached Rapunzel
he gazed at his love
and she said surprise,
I'm an elephant.
[laughter] You've done it again.
You're welcome.
Chicken, I know there is
no elephant in Rapunzel,
that's just plain ludicrous.
Don't you feel sorry
for the elephant, poppa?
All alone waiting for
someone to find him.
Read another story and we'll
find the poor elephant.
Chicken this is silly.
It's my homework.
Ms. Gizzard said
to read three books
and find the elephant
in all of them.
Ok, poppa said, here comes
another story with no elephant.
The Little Mermaid, already
the mermaid could feel the sea
which is potent working,
soon with her new legs she
would dance with the prince
and he would fall
in love with her.
As she crawled out of the waves
a sharp pain passed through her.
She fell to the steps of the
palace and knew only darkness.
When she woke the prince
himself was standing over her.
In the moonlight she saw
that her wish had come true.
She finally did have
legs, elephant legs.
Wow, that was a surprise.
I know. Well chicken,
are you happy?
You put an elephant in every
story but now I'm going
to tell you a story and
I'll make sure there are
no elephants.
Ok poppa and I'll
draw the pictures.
Poppa's story, by poppa, hi,
once there was a poppa whose
daughter loved elephants
and she thought she
saw them everywhere
but there were no elephants.
Every day he got her dressed
but there were no
elephants in the dresser.
Every day he fixed her breakfast
but there were no elephants
in the refrigerator.
And every day he packed
her off to elephant school,
ta da, hi, hop in chicken.
[ Crowd noise ]
Oh poppa, I knew there'd be
an elephant in the story.
So did I, somehow, said poppa.
And it was right at the
end, said the chicken.
What a great surprise.
Are we done, chicken?
Yes, poppa.
Now you can help me
with my math homework.
Because that's the end
of Interrupting Chicken
and the Elephant of Surprise.
[applause] Ta da, thank you.
So how are we for time?
Ok good, we have
some time to do,
I was going to just show you
how I paint an illustration
but I thought maybe I'd
try something a little more
interesting and try to tell
you a story while I do it
at the same time.
So I've never tried this before.
This is, this may fail.
Things might blow up.
I don't know.
We'll find out.
But artists like to take
chances and try new things.
So that's what I'm going to do.
So I have my acrylic,
I have some acrylic paints
here, nice and colorful.
So I'm going to tell you a
little story about a sea worm,
worm that lived in the sea.
There was a sea worm who
went up on top of a cliff
to take a look at the ocean.
Ok so there's the sea worm.
She went on top of a very
tall and skinny cliff to peek
over the edge and see
what she could see.
There she is, skinny
cliff there.
Now all of a sudden
somebody threw a football
and it got stuck in the cliff.
[noise] There's the football and
it's stuck in the cliff, right?
I'm waiting to see if
anybody is picking up on this.
[laughter] Ok, hm, some
people are chuckling a bit.
Now all of a sudden
a big boat came
and it crashed into the cliff.
[noise] Boat came, blue boat,
crashed into the cliff, right?
And it made, I have to
keep changing colors here.
And when that happened
it made a big splash.
[noise] So the big
splash happened.
[laughter] What are you
talking about chickens?
There's no chicken here.
Didn't you pay attention
to the story?
This story is about
a worm, a sea worm.
[laughter] You want to
hear more of the story?
>> Yeah.
>> David Ezra Stein: Ok then
the, so then the boat decided
to try and escape from the
cliff so they put up their sail,
put up a sail on top of the
boat and that didn't work.
So that didn't work so they
had to put out some oars.
Here are the oars,
put out some oars.
A couple of oars came out.
And they had to push
against the rocks.
They pushed against these
two big rocks to get out of,
to get away from the cliff.
[laughter] Wait a minute,
you know I think it looks
a little like a chicken.
That's so weird.
I had no idea that
was going to happen.
And then the worm, well the
worm said this spot is too busy
so it ran away, ran down the
cliff and started to escape
from this wacky place.
[laughter] Alright
you know what?
I mean you're right.
It does kind of look
like a chicken
so maybe I should
put an eye on it
and then a little
dot inside the eye.
That's a good idea.
Good thing I brought some
of this white paint here
so I can paint the
chicken's eye.
And I wish I had some black
paint but I don't have that.
So I have a black marker,
it's a paint marker.
We'll see if it can cover up
the top of the white paint.
Maybe I'll make a
little space for it here.
And we'll put some black
in there and there we go
and we'll do a little
smile, surprise.
[ Applause ]
[ Crowd noise ]
Surprise, I'm a chicken.
[applause] Oh so I
have plenty of time.
I didn't plan anything else
but do you guys have
questions you want to ask?
Yes, how about you?
That's a comfy beanbag
you have there.
[ Inaudible audience question ]
So she knew like pretty early
on that it was going
to be a chicken.
That's very good detective work.
Yeah, how about you?
Nice and loud, ok?
[inaudible audience question]
How long did it take?
How long did it take me to make
that book, Interrupting Chicken
and the Elephant of Surprise?
Well the first one came out
in 2010 so this one's coming
out now so it took, in a
way it took like eight years
or seven years to make.
But really just working on the
artwork took about eight months
to do all those details and
the background and figure
out what the elephant
was going to look like.
I could paint you an
elephant if you'd like.
This time I can't pretend
that it's not an elephant.
It's just going to be a boring,
old, straightforward painting.
Now would anybody like
to take, it's very messy
so parents you have to be ok
with [laughter] Ok it's
wet so just be careful.
>> Thanks.
>> David Ezra Stein: Don't
get it on yourself, ok?
Maybe give it to mom.
Here you want me to, I'll
just hold it here for you.
>> My nickname is chicken.
>> David Ezra Stein:
I'll put it over here.
And you can come
collect it at the end.
So for the elephant
in this story I had
to pick a character that's
very cute and mischievous
and well he doesn't have any
clothes on because he has
to change into all the different
costumes for each story.
So I decided to make an elephant
that looks kind of
like a toddler.
Does anybody know a toddler,
have a toddler in their life?
So they're kind of short
and they have a big head
and they have a cute
belly button, right?
And they have short
legs usually.
So that's what I decided
to do for my elephant.
And it took me a long
time to get the ears
but the ears are this nice like
teardrop upside down shape.
[ Crowd noise ]
Just the ear, I should
make up a story about this.
There were two raindrops
that decided
to go up instead of down.
Hey, look at that.
And then they found a puddle.
They fell in a big puddle.
And they said oh
wow, look at that,
there's more water
up here in the sky.
But then some of the water
decided to turn into a river.
Woo. And then, oh man, then
like a lot of the water started
to leak down, back down to earth
and it grew a belly button.
[laughter] It had to have
been in the little metaphor.
[laughter] Wow, looks
really weird on the screen.
It's very wet so I guess there's
a lot of light reflecting on it.
It looks kind of cool.
And then the elephant has
these stumpy legs here.
Do ta do, a little tail.
He has long arms, actually.
My nephew looks exactly
like this elephant.
He's an unusual kid, no
but he has a big head
and he has short legs
and he's really cute.
So and the elephant
has, I think it's four
or five hairs on
top of its head.
And the elephant is not
complete without eyebrows
because eyebrows
are very expressive
so I decided to give
it eyebrows.
Eyebrows are very important.
So he has one, two,
three, four, five hairs.
He has eyebrows.
[ Crowd noise ]
Do do ta do.
He has big eyes, of course.
[ Crowd noise ]
I forget if he has tusks or not.
Oh well. I think little
elephants don't have tusks
yet so I didn't give him tusks.
And we'll do
[ Crowd noise ]
I think I put my
marker in here, oh.
[ Crowd noise ]
Now for this character he's
all blue so I use a little bit
of lines to make his
trunk pop out and his arms
and legs and I use black.
And all kinds of,
there's all kinds
of blues inside the elephant
if you look in the book,
lots of different
colors of blue.
Ok, oh really?
Ok and then he has
little hairs on the tip
of his tail, four little hairs.
So that's the elephant.
[applause] Thanks everybody.
I got to do the two
characters, two main characters.
So we have time for
one question.
We have less time then I thought
but let's pick somebody
from down here.
>> Me.
>> David Ezra Stein:
How about you?
>> How did you get the
idea to create a father
and a tiny chicken to
read a bedtime story?
>> David Ezra Stein: How did
I get the idea of a father
and a tiny chicken
reading stories together?
Well there's a knock knock joke.
Knock knock?
>> [unison] Who's there?
>> David Ezra Stein:
Interrupting chicken,
bock, bock, bock.
So I heard this knock knock
joke and I thought well
who is this little chicken
and what's the rest
of her life like?
What does she do when she's
not interrupting knocking
on somebody's door?
And so that's where the whole
world of the chicken came about.
And I hope you enjoy the
second book very much.
I'll be signing books
in a little while,
at 12:30 I believe.
So I hope I see you there.
Thanks, you've been
a wonderful audience.
Thank you very much.
[applause]